[Music]
the temple teams were making plans for
their newest addition meet your new but
this baby has a big plans wee babies are
having a crisis babies aren't getting as
much love as we used to behold our
mortal enemy oh no that's exactly the
problem have you learned anything
ABC ye know what have you learned about
puppies hey puppy no Jimbo puppies are
evil Stacey be back the notes I can't
read what's it say boss period oh it's
like they're having their own little
meeting we'll watch dessert this is so
humiliating
you're going to write the anything this
job I know how important this mission is
to the company
Nishi poop duty I've got a deal with the
K ID who are you I'm on a mission
there's not enough love to go around my
job is to find out why they'll give me a
double espresso and see if there's
someplace around here with decent sushi
I kill for a spicy tuna roll right about
now this is war
oh yeah look the kids are finally
getting along that's nice if I don't
succeed with this mission I will live
here forever with you okay I will help
you but just to get rid of you
deal you come no no you're watching Luke
you okay
chew chew on that how do we get past the
guard I've never been so humiliated in
my life I don't we're not gonna sniff it
done to me
what's all the racket isn't he adorable
oh I've got one for you too what bummer
Dean works the bus baby put that cookie
down cookies are for closers
damn look us here meet your new baby Oh
[Music]